what up guys it is Tuesday and it's a
little bit different today we are doing
a a great area reaction and cooling show
so there should be a link in the um
in the in in the comment section right
right blessing right there should be a
link there for anybody's to call in but
myself and pearl are here okay and we
understand
that this lady right here
has got apparently the best legs in the
manosphere I keep saying it pal your
legs are famous you're gonna have to
ensure your legs right now you know that
right ensure them you're gonna have to
destroy your legs oh okay I'll I'll ask
when I get back to the US you need to
talk to your peoples talk to your
peoples and ensure your legs okay I'll
do that I'll do that
um yeah Pearl what what
we saw for the people today
well today we're doing a call
in a reaction video we're going to be
talking about the feminism Fallout
yes the Fallout from feminism yeah yeah
it seems to be going well for them yeah
right what it's going to look like for
feminism in the next what 15 10 to 15
years I I don't know you tell me listen
don't worry I will but do you have any
announcements to make before we actually
get started bill
um
I do I have a couple so
before we even get started oh tell them
oh I was gonna say before we even get
started tell them if you have watched
two or more of our videos how many and
you have not subscribed then we have
what pal beef what do we have beef we
have beef so you better get doing that
right now sorry pal you go ahead and
tell them all right so a couple
announcements the first guys is that we
officially launched episode one of wife
school yes I saw that
um so that's already at like 50k views
in like two days so go subscribe to wife
school I want to get to 10 000 Subs on
the second channel so go subscribe to
that also guys thank you so much for 800
000 subscribers I just like clapping
um it means the world to me that you
guys all subscribe and that you guys
support the channel so much it's mad to
think we only had the first show like
what I not even a year ago eight months
eight months and you said you you knew
it was gonna be huge I told you from the
beginning
listen folks if you go down in pills
like
um all of the videos you will see me
there from the beginning from like eight
months ago you were there before I even
got to London before she got to London
okay so everyone's like who is this dude
yo don't worry about me I've been here
from the beginning from the very from
the jump from the job he was there not
first episode but like second or third
right second yeah my content yeah and
then yeah yeah yeah I've been here
it's like a part of the furniture now
I'm like a part of the family and [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying
um also guys so thank you for 800k go
subscribe to wife school also um is it
members only on tonight blessing yeah so
if you want to be a part of the chat um
sign up for the membership program the
membership's really important because it
gives us um just like a baseline of
recurring Revenue so we know we can
um pay the people the rent the lights
everything like that and
um so and these lights are big yeah
they're very big we're always talking
about light and the lights are big guys
um so make sure you get the first tier
is the price of a cup of coffee a month
and it is a five dollar tier lets you be
a part of the chat 10 tier is a part of
the discords and the behind the scenes
Vlogs I checked the Discord so if you
guys have any any like show topics you
want to submit I really recommend doing
it on the Discord you also get to see
our behind the scenes Vlogs where I
freestyle
um also freestyle you know I can
freestyle you've got bars love it a
little bit
I don't know I I can't say but okay you
get get our second tier you'll see
um third third tier um is you connect
with me on social media fourth chair you
get a one-on-one call with me once a
month so that's the membership tiers
sign up for those if you want to support
the channel
um on top of that go subscribe to Pearl
behind the scenes if you want to see me
live stream randomly with people from
the show and I also will sometimes play
guitar or eat dinner or just like do
random [ __ ] you don't do mukbangs Depot
yeah I do sometimes on there it's just
like Pearl behind the scenes so it's
just like random [ __ ] I'm doing people
just watching you eat food yeah no no
I'll eat and then be like modern women
and then I'll then I'll like eat
something
like that you could also low-key see
blessing on there if you want to see
what he looks like listen blessed is
trying to say low-key Rabbi now
blessings behind the camera trying to
stay low-key but if you want to buy him
a camera for the red amount of super
chats he will come on camera listen yeah
we need more cameras right because
listen this setup is amazing well done
blessing but yeah that's not my
announcement Okay cool so we're going to
talk about the Fallout feminism Pearl
let me ask you a question right in the
next 10 to 15 years what do you think
it's going to look like for the
feminists or for the women that
subscribe to feminism
lonely right real lonely that's what I
think I think the loneliness and
depression of women who subscribe to
um I'm gonna say this because I said
this on my channel right
in the next 10 to 15 years
anybody who has built something like
yourself like myself without the
ideology of feminism
without it the feminists are going to
try and Destroy and attack it
because I think they're depressed and I
think they are
um bitter I think they're angry and I
think they don't think anything can be
built without their ideology
I think that that's true I mean you see
it they do it already they do they do it
already like they always are coming for
me and you on everything on everything I
mean how many times we've been banned
off at Instagram okay I'm on my third
Instagram account I'm on my second but
you know I'll probably be with you soon
but the thing is open all right I think
that the whole feminist ideology right
when I say that I think like family
structure we talk about we talk a lot
about like the family structure and you
know how it's supposed to be you know
the ideal family structure they're going
to try and destroy that
yeah that's true I mean I think you're
going to see an increase in the women
with IVF right and like becoming single
parents with I which I think is really
selfish to like choose to be a single
parent why would you choose that
they're going to come for the family
structure I think they're going to come
for anybody
in the in them let's not say the
minister but in the YouTube space on
social media space that does not
subscribe to their ideology and what
I've seen look at the possible Bros for
instance right people you know there's
guys out there trying to go to different
countries to find a wife or a partner
these women are now making videos saying
these guys are trying to traffic women
and they're trying to have young girls
they're trying to destroy everything
that is not built with their ideology
they are bitter and angry well I think
it's anything that lets men know women's
real value I think that's like what
they're fighting against like they don't
want quality men to go overseas the end
and realize that there's competition
when you don't have to stay at least in
the U.S where 80 of the women are
overweight it's not much better here
it's like 60 years 80 of the women in
the US are overweight yeah
yeah
you were saying what's going on yeah
yeah it's not I forgot what the stats
were here not much better
no but I think it's not much better I'll
say something to know Bill when I went
to when I go to the US because I've been
there a few times right U.S overweight
and UK overweight are two different kind
of overweights obese is 30 pounds or
more but you're right I think we have
more like extreme obesity yeah I've
never seen such extreme obesity
in the UK like the U.S extreme obviously
I was like people have got like blubber
we've had some whales on the show you no
but blubber like
blubber and stuff we've had some tattoos
on the show
that's like my most viral clip is the
the all right that one all right I'll
give you that one you're so British I'll
give you that one I'll give it but
generally like I I went I go over to us
all the time but I've never seen like
people that are that big I feel like
here the British girls are overweight
and the girls that are in shape like
aren't from here
in Europe
you might be right yeah you might be
right you actually might be right well
they're like the most attractive women
aren't like from Britain I found or
they're like yeah you might be right but
the but anyway let's get to the calling
let's get to the reactions as a matter
of fact
um blessing we have a video because you
guys we want you to call in and give
your you know give your takes on on the
videos and myself and pal were gonna you
know speak to you if you wanna speak to
us call in do you know what I mean
um we're gonna have a first video by a
lady Pearl that I've got okay a couple
of weeks ago there was a individual on
the show you said they got beef they got
smoke forever and preach they got smoked
forever and preach
I might I might
have smoke for this lady you might have
smoked I might I might have smoke for
this now I don't normally have smoke for
the opposite sex but in this video once
we play it okay you may understand why
I've got smoke okay okay blessing can we
play can we play this video please
oh Cheyenne Reynolds Cheyenne Reynolds
I've dm'd with her a couple times
let's rewind that let's go sexual and
they're all now with women and they all
say the similar thing where it's kind of
like they've had just traumatic
experiences from men but now it's kind
of like they just feel safe with women
yeah so even just with that like that's
another topic where we need to discuss
like this alarming increase of like
narcissistic behavior is causing us
women to just want to be in same-sex
relationships my friends are actually
bisexual and they're all now with women
and they all say the similar thing where
it's kind of like they've had just
traumatic experiences for men but now
it's kind of like they just feel safe
with women yeah so even just with that
like that's another topic where we need
to discuss like this alarming increase
is causing thank you blessing
po
okay let me just say something first of
all right this is my personal opinion on
Cheyenne Reynolds
what is that what is that noise there
listen can you hear it I hear it
no no I don't um now I hear it you hear
it now I don't thanks okay okay oh yeah
this Cheyenne Reynolds lady
I shouldn't go in on women like this
right but what she said there
was she's basically blaming men
she's blaming men for the reason why so
many women are entering into same-sex
relationships with other women right and
she specifically said
if we listen to what she said she
specifically said that women want to
feel safe because of the narcissistic
characteristics
of other men okay right that's why
they're entering into these safe
relationships
with other women
however pal
17 to 45 percent of lesbians report
having been the victim of at least one
act of physical violence perpetrated by
a lesbian partner according to Susanna
Rose PhD for the national violence
against women Prevention Center
University of Missouri
that's a lot 17 to 45 to 45 of women I'm
not I'm not shocked that does not
surprise me I I think that women are
more violent than men a lot of the time
I mean like because we don't have any
consequence for it you know if you go
punch another dude in the face you're
getting punched back hard you might die
right where women like no girls really I
don't want to say no okay it's not often
that I would be afraid of a girl being
able to kill me with their hands right
it's not I'm not gonna say something no
girl could yeah the average guy could
kill me with his hands yeah yeah
but the thing is it's the fact that she
would sit on a um podcast and say that
women are basically turning into
lesbians because of men
um yeah I don't know why I mean if you
want to lick a vagina say you just want
to lick vagina don't blame us for it I I
have a theory on this go on I I really
think that it's not nothing to do one
it's like you're gonna say narcissistic
man but why don't we why do you like
narcissistic men
maybe it's a you problem like
narcissists are like one to two percent
of the population let's double it
triplet quadruple let's make it ten
percent that's still one out of every
ten guys that's not on every time guys
that aren't why are you picking the
narcissist I don't know because what I'm
gonna do here right okay what I'm gonna
do here
is actually break this down
because a lot of women say that they
were they were with narcissistic men I
want to hear a lot of women say they're
with narcissistic men right a lot of
women say oh do you know what my ex
wasn't we've heard it on the show right
oh always my ex was a narcissist I've
never heard a guy say his ex was a
narcissist that's a funny thing do you
know why I tell you why because what
we're gonna do have you heard of the
diagnostic statistical Manual of mental
health disorders okay go ahead the DSM
five it is the it is the the Bible of
Psychiatry and psychology
and so narcissism is actually
a mental health disorder right but in
the diagnostic statistical Manual of
mental disorders there are nine
narcissistic characteristic traits to
show that you are a narcissist okay
number one
an inflated sense of self-esteem a
grandial sense of self-importance or
superiority okay
does that sound like I'm a 10.
thank you
does that sound like the man or the
woman
okay someone who is craving admiration
you go girl you go girl
exploitative relationships I.E
manipulation
little to no empathy
okay identity is easily Disturbed
meaning they cannot handle criticism
I mean
[Music]
the lack of attachment and intimacy
modern women
feelings of depression or emptiness when
they are not validated
oh yeah that's that's women that's right
yeah I think that's just women in
general I sense of entitlement modern
women
can feel like others are envious of them
or others are oh they meet and may be
envious of others yeah
I'm trying to understand right like
women use the term narcissism all the
time so if listen everybody can go and
research what narcissism is
um and the traits of narcissism I don't
understand what I do because projection
is a thing
these women are projecting their own
narcissistic traits onto other men and
saying that the men are narcissistic
yeah I think so well that's the thing
like you are what you attract so if you
if you dated three narcissists you might
be well I'll give you do one I'll give
you we're attracted to the dark Triad
traits and [ __ ] you know what I'll give
y'all one narcissist but they all were
all of them all of them every single
last one of them I'll give I'll give you
one I won't give you two because
narcissists are supposed to be like what
two percent two like ten percent of the
population that's not a big percentage
but every woman that comes on the show
or speaks on a podcast says that their
man was a narcissist well my question is
well why do you attract narcissists no
but if you read the the I'm giving I
just give too much you read the criteria
of announces though do you does that man
fit all those nine criteria
criteria
oh there's one I'll read them again
there's one guy I could think of maybe
that inflated sense of self-esteem okay
grandiose self-importance and
superiority
yeah yeah okay craving admiration
yeah
exploitative relationships I.E
manipulation little to no empathy
yes can't handle criticism
yes lack of attachment and intimacy
I could think of my
person no you think of one person okay
sense of entitlement
no no I would say that would you say
that the shows that we've been doing for
the past eight months eight nine months
oh it's mostly women right you just
asked if I could think of any guy and
like I could think of one but the thing
is it's mostly in my experience it's
mostly the women that are having these
traits absolutely no it's absolutely
women more than men so women would you
say that women are more narcissistic
than men
I think social media proves that
like like what is more narcissistic than
so social media it's very true that's
the thing like I feel like
I feel like social media can breed
narcissism and I think women who's more
addicted to social media women well
we're talking about the full out of
feminism so okay
one of the fallouts of feminism that I
can see in the next 10 to 15 years is
that women
are going to be very lonely and
depressed
and one of the things blessing if you
queued a second video
is that women are going to end up doing
this
second video please blessing
yeah he's gonna queue up
um yeah the women are going to end up
doing this pill
I'm telling you
they don't understand what a Fallout of
feminism actually is
because women are no they say they don't
need men
We Don't Need No Man you don't need no
man girl I do you do I do but the
feminists the ultra feminist Super
Saiyan feminists the ones that are like
the Ultras uh say they don't I don't
need a man I Don't Need No Man for
anything as a matter of fact they prefer
silicon
ew
they prefer their vibrators right
right they prefer the vibrators let's
see let's see what the Fallout feminism
is please bless him let's see what this
woman has to say
oh
about one if you don't know what it is
Google it
so my very best friend JLo told me that
I had to have one they are amazing okay
comes in the mail I read on it it's
waterproof you can use it shopping
driving probably don't recommend that
either
standing walking sitting however you
want to use it you can use it okay don't
recommend it standing either and I'll
tell you why
so I decide I'm gonna use it in the
shower one because it's waterproof you
know okay so I gotta get in the shower
find my speed that I want
10 speed draw there's 10 speeds 10
speeds though okay I'm getting into it
next thing I know my knees start to
freaking book
my toes are curling I'm grasping for
anything okay with one hand because I'm
not letting go without I'm grasping air
will not catch you okay you can't catch
air air will not prevent you from
falling
learned that the hard way next thing I
know my eyes roll back in the back of my
head it started with memories from 40
years ago y'all I'm not the 36. then
next thing I know I'm in 1912 selling
the Titanic okay that's how far back my
eyes went in my head I'm selling the
Titanic we're fixing to hit the iceberg
when I come to I pop myself in the back
of the head my eyes rolled forward and I
realized that I have a death grip on
Rosie so had I died
in my shower that day
I would have died with a death grip on
Rosie with that's how my family would
have found me
now I do recommend it I don't recommend
it in the shower don't try to read the
directions either because they're in
Chinese
you cannot read the directions okay but
good luck in Godspeed
why why did you do that to me
I feel so uncomfortable why did you do
that to me well women are celebrating
silicone I don't I don't understand why
you would put that on the internet I'm I
put a lot on the internet I understand
putting some things you know I
understand I tell funny stories on the
internet
but
ew I just don't you I don't want to hear
about that I don't want to know you no
The Fallout of feminism is because women
have been told for so long that they no
longer need a man
they are seeking certain things sexually
from silicone toys and this woman is
celebrating her silicone toy now I don't
have a problem as a man with being
replaced
by silicone Target because I know that
silicon toys aren't fixed shelves
silicone toys do not kill spiders
silicone toys do not take you out on
dates silicone toys
hug you at night time Poe look if they
want to if they want to replace men with
that be my freaking guess that is that
sounds like a her problem
you you
yeah I mean
um the a couple of shows ago we I spoke
about
um there were certain companies who deal
in sex toys who have seen like a 20 to
25 rise in you know sales and stuff and
I think that is one of the main
um one of the things about feminism or
Ultra feminism I've always called it
Super Saiyan feminism
um with this I don't need a man stuff is
that women are trying to replace men
with things that men cannot be replaced
by
and I think um
women I used to spoke about you know
women being lonely
and I went on a website called
loneliness.com
it's called rootsofloneliness.com and it
says the common causes of female
loneliness include
not having friends on meaningful
connections with others
living away from family
spending too much time on social media
dealing with mental illness living alone
not having your romantic needs met
being single being a parent raising a
child alone struggles with
self-confidence self-esteem or
self-worth struggles with
eating disorders and body image
that sounds accurate yeah that sounds
right I feel like women being lonely is
a new phenomenon I feel like men have
always been lonely because most men have
not reproduced historically or I feel
like be it women being lonely is almost
like a newer phenomenon yes because like
you at least work concubine or something
yeah you know you might not have gotten
like first round attention but do you
think that you think women do with
loneliness
worse than men
um yeah I do I think like women are more
communal and we value relationships more
so when we're by ourselves like I feel
like man like women are more interested
in people where men are more interested
in things well one of the things that
says that women uh you know not having
any meaningful connections with others
yeah no I agree yeah yeah
I've even heard like some girls if
they're single and they also don't have
a good relationship with their immediate
family and I'm like I can't even imagine
a relation like a world where you grew
up in a great a huge family right yeah
and I can't even imagine not like going
home for Christmas some people are like
yeah I'm not going home for Christmas
I'm like what I can't even imagine like
not going home for Christmas my mom
would kill me
I would literally be murdered like it'd
be like where's Pearl what what do you
think like the classic like
for men to look out for and also for
women like what do you think like the
classic things to look out for for like
an ultra feminist is
um because I would say
blue hair
dude I feel like that blue hair red hair
green hair I could see some that are so
obvious like you know a bunch of tattoos
tattoos piercings yeah crazy colored
hair
um
I I think you can also hear it in her
language like is she bitter
and I just think you don't want to date
a girl that's like bitter
but when you what do you mean by bitter
like like does she blame men for her
poor choices right you know like being a
lesbian
like Cheyenne Reynolds said she's gonna
blame men for being a lesbian but God
yeah and that's what I mean like like
you can't blame all of men for your poor
decisions and it's like I think some
girls come out of it I mean
I don't want to sit like some girls come
out like worse than us
I don't know you could just hear it in a
girl's like voice and the way she talks
if she's too damaged
okay you know what I mean because she's
just bitter what do you think causes
that damage though
Chad Tyrone
Chad Tyrone so one of the things here is
like it says about female depression or
female loneliness is like not having
your relationship or not having your
romantic needs met
yeah I mean I think we're biologically
predispositioned to want children so I
just think like as women we want we want
to have kids and when we get past a
certain age and we don't have them
like I just think it's lonely but then
why are women not having children
um I mean I think it's more like can't
get the guy because I ask I ask girls
this all the time on the show and I'm
like if you could
um
like if you found a guy that had
everything you wanted would you want a
child with him and the answer is yes but
it's it's so to me it's like not getting
finding a guy you want to have a kid
with or being able to attain one and
it's partially because like I just think
women oftentimes like we're kind of
blind to what men even want
like we've gone through our lives like
men have always had to hear what well
yeah what we want but like we've never
been told what you guys want
but then do women care do you think
about what men want
um no
until it's too late and then I started
and then I thought okay because it's
like
your relationship needs all or your
romantic needs are not being met
I think that the Romantic needs of the
modern day woman by a little bit
delusional so obviously you're going to
be depressed because no one can meet
those needs well yeah because they're
just
some of this [ __ ] is crazy
I I hate when girls say they won't do
coffee as a first date
I think that's the stupidest [ __ ] I've
ever heard they're like I'm like if he
doesn't know you why wouldn't
what do they normally say that the first
date should be then dinner
what a specific restaurant
I don't know they just say dinner and
I'm like I mean Coffee Spot first date
you're just getting to know each other
so would you go on a coffee date for the
first date I have hell yeah right okay I
almost prefer it because it's like
I I just feel like it's less pressure I
don't know I I like coffee dates yeah I
like you like coffee in general though I
do like coffee you like coffee no but
I've quit I'm day one sober day one of
coffee and coffee yeah I fell asleep for
like three hours today
but yeah it's like if you don't get your
see I think well we've spoken about it
many times I think the
the requirements for the modern day
woman and what they want from romantic
relationships right now are delusional
so I think if you've if you have said I
want X Y Zed six figures six pack you
know all the sixes and you're not gonna
get that and you've built your whole
being on getting that you're gonna do
you're gonna be depressed and lonely
yeah
so do you think that like
feminists are making themselves yeah of
course your personality yeah yes
yeah
yeah you ain't wrong like I don't I
don't think you're wrong I think I think
women are actually
actively making themselves lonely yeah I
mean everything in life is a choice so I
mean there's like
red like there is always a guy out there
yeah there's always so it's like yeah
that's gonna what adhere to everything
that she wants
I hate to like I hate to say it but yeah
yo I'm saying like it's true and so it's
like well we're men like he may not have
Okay like like women even if she's obese
like there's always another like a guy
that'll that'll like still deal with her
but men on the other hand like there are
some guys that like genuinely know women
will deal with
I've always said a woman you've said a
woman can be like 500 pounds
life half of them have like feeder
boyfriends I mean imagine I was like 600
pounds I wouldn't be able to find a
woman no as handsome as I am I think
folks like I don't think I'll be able to
find 600 pounds would not suit you it
wouldn't suit me at all you know
um blessing do we have people who want
to call in oh we do we're gonna get some
coolers emperor
and get the first caller in
alrighty
is ready
oh
hello
here hi
you guys hear me yeah we can hear you
loud and clear
awesome hey Pearl hi
uh is it Sarah Sarah don't worry you can
sorry you can speak to Pearl Pearl I
think you're here for Pearl right now I
think it's happy for you but oh yeah
yeah
um I just wanted to say that
I get a little
what's it called the Reverb
okay uh anyway
um maybe a turn your to maybe turn the
actual video down
turn the video down and just speak to us
without the video volume that might help
oh
okay I'll just try my best here so I
just want to say um I I really like what
you're doing Pearl um I want you to
understand that there are certain
beliefs that I have that
make me think that you're fighting an
uphill battle that is going to be
overwhelming for you eventually this is
why I say this
so
when you look at the root word of sodomy
you know you know what it is it's
actually something that came from the
Bible
well here's the thing behind that
there's a lot of corruption a lot of
what we are seeing right now that is
kind of like the upbringing
like the whole transgenderism lesbian
gays and all that stuff
that is something that is going to be
even more pronounced eventually in the
future where it's going to be
all accepted eventually
well
history shows an archaeologists have
confirmed that there was an actual
couple City Sodom and Gomorrah that were
actually destroyed how were they
destroyed they were destroyed by
Brimstone and sulfur
well there is no other place in this
world that you can find that and so the
archaeologists pointed to the Bible and
said okay
something caused these things to come
down well they just don't magically
appear I do believe in God and I do
believe that in the historical event
that God did that well why did he do
that
well because this world became so
corrupted well I'm sorry that that those
cities came became so corrupted that
um sexual immorality you're talking
about
um uh you know the whole lesbian thing
in in transgender and whatnot
um
the marriage out of I'm sorry not
marriage just uh sex out of wedlock and
stuff like that things like that
um and he got to a point of like
even bestiality and stuff like that so
he burnt all that down that place is
uninhabitable
this world is gonna end that way that's
why I'm saying you're fighting an uphill
battle because you're going to see a lot
of this thing going
uh it's going to be overwhelming and
stuff like that but I'm really glad what
you're doing because
uh us guys we need uh a voice to speak
for us that is not from guys that's from
a from a girl's perspective you know and
and that's why I'm glad that that you're
doing what you're doing
um I have been married to someone that I
didn't know was with another woman prior
to and that was something that I should
have you know prodded
prior to my marrying her but I didn't do
that
um it lasted 10 years and after that she
requested the divorce or she asked for
the divorce without divorce and stuff
like we had a a a a little girl so I
decided you know I'm not going I'm gonna
go down can I ask can I ask you a
question can I ask you a question abroad
can I ask you a question okay oh yeah go
ahead go ahead yeah did you when your
wife filed for divorce did she divorce
you to go and be with another woman or
did she divorce you to go and be with
another man
it took me to be another woman
wow wow
yes so and now my daughter's having a
so what do you what do you think is in
the future you think that like they're
gonna burn all the cities down like what
what are you for correct
yes so what happens is
there's this thing called the image of
God which we are the image of God
and the opposite of that would be Satan
so Satan is trying to take the image
away from God
and so what is the image of God he
created a marriage
so the marriage has been treating two
people and that's the Covenant right
there
so what do you do now you separate that
you Empower one that is not supposed to
be empowered which is the woman because
the man is supposed to be the leader
so can I ask a question so you see you
see your your your your lady left you
for another woman
um
did you at any point in time during that
relationship did you know that she was
that way inclined so she was 100 totally
heterosexual with you
after about five or six years
she let me know of her deepest darkest
secret which was that
interesting okay
um
wow you know it was a little difficult
um
but then
it
made it it makes it easier for me to
Let It Go and to find closure
how are you doing how are you doing
after the divorce
I found my lady
that I'm currently married now but I'm
married are you married again you're
married again yes I am okay I I found
her abroad
where where did you find that possible
bro
[Laughter]
that's right okay so I'm trying I'm
petitioning Iran to get over here let me
let me let me ask you a question because
people always talk about the passport
Bros and people going abroad you know to
find a woman what she was she a younger
woman was she a child
because this is what people are saying
they say that you know people are going
abroad to find very younger women who
are impressionable
he's actually five years younger than me
I'm 43. oh okay well she's over eight
yeah she okay you said you're married
she's not here yet
she's not here yet no oh okay
hang on whoa whoa whoa so you married
over there
no I married online
well this just got interesting how the
hell do you marry online bro like what
the hell is that
so there is this uh gentleman that was
finally on YouTube he is actually
Filipino he married his wife as well
this was during the pandemic
so then this company from Utah
they do online marriages and they're
actually
um legitimate because the board the
what's it called the um my bro my bro
have you seen this woman have you met
her in real life
uh yes I went over there for a month in
April okay so you met you met her for a
month and then you got married online
and how we got married before I met her
wow okay back back
so you you married a woman before you
met her
before I met her physically yes
ow why
she could have been anybody I
he could have been yeah she could
still but the thing is
um
I I went with that route because I
wanted to go sit with someone that was
within my religion
and that was my problem before
all right which is fine you can have
your religion but I'm just talking about
like Common Sense type stuff like how
can you marry somebody that you've never
met
right you've never seen you've never
touched
and you're gonna you're gonna
wholeheartedly devote the rest of your
life to somebody like that
correct so
the way I see things is
not really like other people say like
hey this is the norm
um
it's definitely not the norm bro
it's definitely not the norm
you know what I mean and but if you
think about it what was the norm back in
the days you would go and you talked to
the the Father the Father the father
yeah
yeah correct but you would but you but
you but you but you would have seen him
do it
but you yeah but you would have
taught her
how long have you been married now
um it'll be our first our year our year
anniversary in uh January 18th okay and
since you've been married how many times
you've seen her
um just the whole month of April
so you've seen uh the whole month of
April since you've been married and
since April and today and right now
we're in December
you haven't seen your woman since April
no but I I'm I'm playing with this whole
thing I'm gonna go back again probably
March
more than likely
are you are you do you send her money do
you send her money yes
my bro no no no no no but I what do you
mean by that though what was the
question the question
I I just I hope it works out I'm not
they're they're like I just I don't know
if it's wise to like be sending a girl
money that you've met once for a month
I'm married and married like someone
online that's not normal
like I I I don't know a single married
person that's done that you know
but no no I hear you I hope it works out
for you
um it seems like you're already too deep
in this really we're really
um into the church we're really into
worshiping we call each other we worship
you know
um
yeah that's very important to us
because
at the end of the day let's say
we get into an argument
well you have to have a standard
and you have to be able to look at
something to be able to mitigate that
argument so we just pray together what
do you I mean what do you argue about if
you see each other once a year
no no I mean it's really
really is it like you turned up late for
the for the zoom meeting though like is
that what you argue about like what the
hell no no like for example we had a
little argument and say that I I'm I'm
trying to do a bunch of things at the
same time I'm trying to like send to my
daughter trying to go to school I have
two jobs and then I have my wife
so I'm trying to petition her
so she's asking hey can you
um
do this with with respect to the
petition I go I can do it yeah I can do
it just give me some time what do you
mean by petition what do you mean
repetition what do you mean petition
means uh getting her took over here to
the United States legally okay okay
so it's taken from April to December
she's still not over here
okay yes actually July is when I
petitioned her
so do you so yeah
30 32 36 36 okay so has she got children
has she been married before or she's no
no children and never been married Okay
and like how and you just met her
through this organization or your church
so I I made it through the church
listen I I I hope it all works out for
you I'm just saying
um
that that when I always say passport
Bros this isn't what we've made yeah
like this is the thing it's like you I
think that men generally need to be a
little bit smarter with you know when
they talk about going to meet people
abroad or finding a woman from abroad
because if you've seen this woman once
in April and then you got married to her
and now you're trying to get her
overhead I'm not saying listen I'm not
trying to disrespect you
um
um it just seems like there hasn't been
enough time
that's been invested into this person on
a personal level for you to get married
to her and for you to you know I guess
trust her to be your wife she's in a
whole another country you're ever you're
in a whole nother country you're trying
to get her over here I understand that
you're trying to get her over here
um but
yeah it just kind of it just seems a
little bit
how much how much have you spent on her
like sent her money like you send the
money every month
so um she got a new apartment
I want to say
or months ago with with your money
no uh
so she was she's working as a registered
nurse at the Advent one of our uh the
religious um
the Adventist Medical Center are you
Seventh-day Adventist and so I'm
Seventh-day Adventist yeah I grew up
7-Day Adventists oh did you yeah I did
oh awesome so yeah so over there in
Adventist Medical Center Manila that's
where she works okay
uh as a single person you get to live at
the dorm for free at the hospital
he once they get married they have to go
uh abroad and so they have to pay for
their own way now okay and so what she
was doing is uh she was I think she said
she's paying like she wasn't for free I
think she was paying like 2 000 pesos
can I just get this in US Dollars just
like I'm sorry how much how much a month
for how long he was like two thousand
was like a hundred bucks 100 bucks a
month
yeah that's what she was paying okay so
that's how much you're sending her every
month
no no I'm sending her 140. okay
okay so the reason I'm saying 140
is because she found an apartment that I
was like
I think it was this is your wife does it
yeah
did the church get like a cut of
anything for setting you guys up
no no okay
okay the the church had no idea okay I
wasn't sure like the organization you
guys used or whatever it was no that was
just an online service that was a bunch
of denominations but I looked for us
when I was Seventh-Day Adventists
um I wanted to say that my reason for
looking abroad was that I noticed that
did I hear the I
the the whole
ideology and stuff like that the the
perception of how a man should be how a
woman should be I didn't like it
I like the laws that they have over
there because
over there
it doesn't matter whether you're
Seventh-day Adventist whatever
domination you are you can't get
divorced for whatever reason
you have it has to be infidelity right
and it has to be proven right so I
already like that fact
two in our religion we know that we're
not the only way that we're going to get
divorced is adultery right
or in other words
in God's eyes that he would allow you to
do it even though he was he that's
frowned upon okay because what does he
say forgiveness
Okay so
I decided you know what I'm gonna go
that route
can I can I ask you a question how how
how long before she because how long
before she comes to the country
it's already been since July so the
Vermont Center is saying another four
months
wow so net and so near enough a year
before you've seen her near enough
okay
yeah but I I still plan to go over there
to go see uh hi to the in-laws and all
that stuff
okay yeah
it's funny because my even my wife asked
me she says babe why don't you look for
someone closer there in the United
States
I said babe
um
I know what kind of ladies are here
and if I was to look for someone that
was close to my age
she's probably had already a body count
so fair enough fair enough I'm not gonna
go that route
and my wife did not have a body count
she had no body count so Pat what are
your final thoughts on this
I mean she says she's no body count but
you know
um well I mean I was with her I can
confirm that I was nobody
fair enough okay so you consummated a
marriage before the marriage is what
you're trying to say no he met her after
they're married
yeah indeed so obviously you consummated
the marriage okay yeah yeah so yeah we
we met September
2020. yeah so how long before you got
married before you met her after you met
her sorry
um
it was about what a year now so you were
speaking for a year year and a half I'm
saying until she was 34 36 36 36 when
you met her and she was a virgin at 36.
yes
yes
okay her
um I just had a nurse he's 52 years old
still a virgin
um I I just think maybe you don't under
um these hoes be lying and I'm not
saying that like it's her that she is
but it's just like any any girl can like
say things
um I just don't think it's overly like
probable
that by 36 there's not a single guy
that's that's touched her at 52 like I
just don't
um there just seems to be like a lot of
like red flags on this whole situation
if you could if you can speak to a girl
for a whole year
within that time I'm not saying you
don't build a connection because you
don't you do build a connection with
somebody who you're speaking to
but to marry them for me I can't
understand them maybe maybe it's my
ignorance with being in the Western
World I don't know
um
to be speaking to somebody and not being
able to fill them or touch them
physically and actually marry them
without being able to do so
is a very foreign concept to me
do you know what I mean that's a foreign
concept
it is it is
um it's not impossible though no no it's
not impossible I understand that it's
very foreign absolutely but this is the
route that we both chose to take because
we found that connection
amongst each other and that we both rely
on God to help us on that end so that
actually helps us a lot
okay listen how long have you been well
well I mean I grew up seven-day
Adventists I grew up um I grew up seven
in Venice I'm not I would no longer
count myself as a Sunday event seven-day
Adventist oh I hear it okay like but I
did grow up in the Seventh Day Adventist
Church that's how I grew I hear you I
hear you well I I hope it works out for
you
um
wow that's a crazy story it's crazy but
thank you for sharing yeah thanks for
sharing yeah I hope it works out for you
okay all right thank you blessing thanks
thank you
interesting that's interesting right
well you think she's a virgin no that's
what he said 36.
I don't know okay I don't know any 36 of
it is 36 year old virgins over here
but let's not say it may be possible
maybe possible
that's not what I meant when they said
passport Bros
hi how you doing hello pretty good how
are y'all doing good we're good we're
good
can you hear me okay yeah you're
absolutely fine
okay so I have a couple of questions
it's kind of a two-parted question
so I know what you guys do a lot of is
kind of preaching to the choir
um do you think there's a constructive
conversation to have with modern women
um
people call them that disagree but it's
it's usually more
at some point they're too far gone one
but like there's some that maybe aren't
as you know what I'm saying like like
the ones that are younger I think maybe
they'd be like suede yeah but it's like
at 35 35 32 it's like what what's gonna
change your opinion at that point
um I would say with like the younger
generation but like in general I just
tell guys to date younger because like
it's just easy they're less traumatized
less of a headache yeah yeah I think
there's a constructive conversation I
think the constructive conversation like
Pearl was saying is with the younger
generation
um
excuse me sorry I don't think I don't
think that it's constructed with the
older generation because the older
generation like I was saying earlier on
this show in the show is the ones that
are going to try and destroy
anything that you built without their
ideology because they're they're
starting to realize now
oh damn I actually I I I chose the wrong
path right and so when you realize you
chose the wrong path and you have an ego
and pride you don't necessarily you
don't want to admit that you've done
wrong you don't want to admit that
you're you were in a wrong right so
these people that the older generation
are going to be the bitter old angry
depressed generation the younger
generation can can actually be saved I
think
yeah I I think so too
and then I wanted to ask also have you
guys found any points
um that resonated with younger women
yes
um really yes I I there was a specific
woman that was
on the show Once I don't remember her
name we've done so many shows so many
shows right
um but when I was speaking after the
show
chic she said to me you know what I have
never had anybody
speak
about this stuff in the way you guys
have spoken about it and it's kind of
opened my mind whereas her being I think
she was like 21 22. and everything that
she'd been fed to up to that age had
been you know the from older but you
don't think there's any points that
specifically resonate with like women in
general I can't think of any uh like I
would say like certain women sure but
women in general do you know what it is
po I think I think all the points that
we make resonated women but they are so
stubborn right that they refuse to let
it permeate they know women in general
know that what we're saying makes sense
[Laughter]
yeah that's true they know they know it
right yeah
permeate right and so that's the thing
it's like if you know something makes
it's like if you know one plus one is
two right and you're fighting like
674. you still know you still know it's
two but because of the fact that you are
hanging all of your
I guess emotions on the fact that it's
674. like you just won't say it's two
you know what I mean so I think most of
the women that come on the show know
that what we are saying makes sense
however
they just they're so stubborn
and and that's why I said and that's
what going back to what you say modern
day women are some of the most stubborn
they're the most stubborn yeah gone
they're some of the most stubborn and
vindictive and hard-headed women that
you'll ever come across that's what I've
personally come to realize
yeah because I feel like there's a lot
of finger pointing and I think a man men
listen and they're like okay you know
how can I work on myself so how can I
get six-pack a six-pack how can I get
six figures you know to you know meet
these standards but whenever you say
like okay but you know I don't want you
to dress like a hoe and go out to the
clubs every weekend you know it's like
that becomes a problem like don't
control how I dress or you know just all
those kinds of things it's like it turns
back on us and I just feel like there's
no wanting to take like okay you know if
I want you to make 80 to 100 a year
I can you know be more modest around
yeah but you know what I mean yeah but
that's the uh that's thinking about the
stubbornness
women know that if they want to keep
their man just like men know if they
want to keep their woman
they're gonna have to be certain
um
compromises that have to be made the
problem is with the problem is with the
modern day woman is they don't think
they need to compromise route for
anything or anyone they think they don't
it's like men are more than willing to
compromise oh 100
yeah you see the amount of whales that
have boyfriends right because they've
compromised but the modern day woman and
that's why I said at the beginning when
we talk about the feminism Fallout women
are going to be the ones that are most
affected by feminism not men it's these
women that have taken on this ideology
that refused to compromise that refuse
to listen that refused to even take on
anything other than the feminist idology
in a in 10 to 15 years they are going to
be the most angry and bitter individuals
that you will ever find and like I said
I'm going to tell you as a brother and
I'm going to tell all the women be very
careful of those women because they will
try to sabotage
everything
that has been built without it ideology
they're gonna they're gonna try and
sabotage your family they're going to
try and sabotage any family that's been
built without their ideology right
they're going to try and sabotage it
they're going to tell you they're going
to try and go for the women they're
going to tell the women that they're
quote unquote what pick means
right yeah we've already seen it they're
going to tell them that they're pick
means they're going to tell them that
you know that's they're they're idiots
they're going to tell the men that
they're misogynistic they can tell the
man that they're patriarchal all this
kind of all of it is it's just sabotage
all of these modern day women are just
trying to sabotage because things are
now being built and people are now
having a different ideology to what they
have
yeah because I feel like in 10 to 15
years
I'll still be able to get a girl that's
25. you know what I mean how do you know
25. there you go oh yo oh definitely
you're definitely 10 in 10 years you're
going to be 35 you you'll definitely get
a 25 year old no no yeah oh no problem
those women are still going to be 35 40
right they're going to be 35 40. looking
at you saying looking at you telling you
oh my God you're a pedophile because you
want to get with it
right that's what I'm saying they're
going to do anything to sabotage and I'm
and I'm telling people from now the the
modern day the modern day feminist Ultra
feminist Super Saiyan feminist in 10 to
15 years is going to be the most
vindictive evil woman that you would
ever come across she's gonna try and
sabotage everything this part is she'll
sabotage younger women yeah that's like
that's it that pisses me off above all
else is like when older women sabotage
younger women it's like if you're gonna
if you're going to take owls can you
just take the L's and like at least
teach the Next Generation like that's
what I appreciate about Auntie like she
was a single mother I love yeah but she
was a single mother but she'll come like
she'll come out and say no I shouldn't
have been like I made poor decisions
right and that's and that's the thing
like like modern women will die on the
hill that they've never 100 that would
die and try and bring other people to
die with them yeah misery loves you yeah
misery loves company that will bring all
of them yeah going sorry bro uh no good
I that's why I like when you and I mean
it's kind of rude I guess but when you
say whales it's like it's not healthy or
cute or cool to be out of shape
no you know what I mean and it's like
and any woman that's saying like you go
girl body positivity it's like no you're
saying that because you're 130 pounds
well and it's one thing making fun of
someone for something they can't change
but like honestly if they got called
like I was I was anti sometimes like
she's very blind but it's kind of
helpful because it's like when someone
makes fun of you for something you want
to change it right and are you working
that bullying they said I'm not saying
I'm like so we all never have brother
brothers to bully you and it shows it
shows honestly I believe my sister I'm
gonna I'm gonna lie yeah yeah I'll call
my brother now and thank him yeah
but yeah I mean it's like you know I
can't change how tall I am but it's not
a problem to hear a woman say you oh you
aren't six foot
right but I can't say like you need to
lose a little bit of weight or like I
don't want to be with you anymore you
put on 50 60 pounds and they can change
that that's not okay
within their power yeah 100
well that was pretty much all my
questions I'm glad you guys had time for
me listen bro yeah thanks thank you very
much for calling in calling again
I will do take it easy
thank you blessing oh we got someone
else oh hi straight in
hi hey can you guys hear me yeah we can
hear you loud and clear
okay perfect
well hopefully uh you guys are doing
good
um
yeah love your work pearl big fan
um usually I see your stuff on Tick Tock
until you get banned but
that's so that's where I saw this live
you know you guys started this up or
whatever Mr raw nice that's YouTube
thank you very much
so it's okay I I I know you have a power
it's okay it's fine right now I know
you're right you're just as good don't
worry but
um so one of the questions I have is is
uh Pearl a lot of the times you talk
about how men like today young virgins
and uh I just wanted to know do you
think that there's any value of having
like uh
like do you think there's any value of
having some sexual experience to like
judge if you and your partner are like
sexual or sexually compatible
um do I think there's any value for the
manner for the women
well for as it can like from a male's
point of view is it good to like
personally I think I want to have a girl
who has a little bit of experience like
I don't know if I would necessarily like
if I had to have a lineup I don't know
if I would choose somebody who was a
show who was a virgin or and obviously
you don't want somebody who is you know
like
like run through or anything like that
but maybe somebody who has a few
Partners who was in like trying to have
a real relationship with people and has
maybe like a few numbers under her bill
like under 10 or something like that was
just having some like if because if I
know what I want and she could like it's
like almost like test driving a car I
don't know if I would want to
um like if the car wasn't what I like I
don't want to commit to it or I don't
know does that like do value her
anywhere I don't know
are you really funny are you religious
um so I I grew up in religious but I'm
not currently religious yeah I mean I
think it sounds like you wouldn't want
to wait till marriage to have sex
not me personally yeah but yeah so it's
it's kind of like if you get to the
girls what do you mean
well so like I I don't think I'm like I
don't want to wait but the I know you
say that that um when you're talking to
women you're telling them to you know
one of the advice is like the younger
you can be and the less Partners you can
have the better for women yeah yeah
exactly
so I'm just saying if you think there's
any value of having a few Partners or
like to see what you like what you don't
like and kind of get an experience do I
think there's any value no not really
um I mean I just think
most guys with their wife like the less
Partners the better
um but maybe some guys don't really want
to wait till they're married to have sex
so like it doesn't really make sense for
them to go for a virgin because they'd
want to wait you know do you think do
you think men shouldn't have sex to
online
um I think for a virgin sure why would
you wait if she's not a virgin that
doesn't really make sense
what I'm saying do you think you think
like men should be also virgin until
marriage
uh I I don't really have a strong
opinion on like what people do I don't I
don't really care if a guy wants to wait
like there's two strategies you could go
for so like some guys try to screw as
many girls as possible in order to
attract more women because like women
value pre-selection so that's like one
mating strategy guys do
um another one is to find a virgin that
you have similar values with and to wait
till marriage
um
I don't I don't really have a strong
opinion either way I don't think it
affects guys as much as it affects girls
I totally agree yeah but as you so the
root of the question is though like that
do you see how I would like want more
compatibility or like I'm not I'm not a
virgin but I don't I don't really care
if she is either to be honest
yeah um I don't think most what do you
think you think most guys want virgins I
feel like because when I'm talking about
it I'm talking about like guys
evolutionarily like that's what I'm
saying like like from a biological
person men want young virgins yes in a
religious sense yes however we're living
out most people are quote unquote
secular right and so
sorry most people are yeah okay
um
most men in these days and times are are
corn
corn not corn addicts but they've been
watching corn right and so with corn
corn kind of
excuse your view on sex
and so
a lot of men are looking for a woman
so crazy a lot of men are looking for a
woman who can do the things that they
see in corn but they want a virgin but
they want somebody innocent also so it's
like men have a men have a lot of men
not saying all but a lot of men have
this this schizophrenic bipolar thing in
their head where they want their woman
to know all of these things that the
that you know she can swing from the
chandeliers right but be innocent at the
same time it's very weird
I'm thinking about your question more I
think data wise optimally it's two
virgins is the best that's what it says
yeah because I'm thinking like my my
parents have only like been with each
other yeah and I feel like it's kind of
better that way because like there's no
exes around town There's no like stories
of your parents like when they're like
that's never happened but we don't
necessarily this is a thing po we don't
live in that world right now I know that
that's something that's why we got like
when they're like well like do you want
to Verge it's like well like The Virgins
of today aren't the virgins of yesterday
because the problem is and this is what
I've heard from guys like the virgin
girls of today like get curious
right and like that's why they're the
Virgin today is somebody who's had five
bodies
that's a version of today
like a virgin five five bodies is that
all you're a virgin do you know what I'm
saying like that's the that's the
version of today like the [ __ ] of today
someone who's had 20 30 40 right but the
version of today somebody's got five
bodies so this is the thing is like
we're moving with the times in which
we're living in
generally when you're on the dating
Market you know the dating app data
people on data app saying virgins
people on dating apps are not virgin
spells you know what I mean it's like
the lower the body count the better but
better religious and I just think for
guys it doesn't matter as much but for
girls it matters more
in what do you mean like the bodies like
for girls they matter more like it seems
to affect women more than right 100
thank you for calling in
yeah you take care thanks yeah bye-bye
um forgot about that I know I did too I
was like I didn't bring my laptop but I
was like oh yeah
um okay NJ
love your message hate to see people my
age I'm 20 listening to advice from the
woke stuff
um
how is Cheryl just left a very long one
okay hey freckles don't
don't read my super chats out loud okay
then I won't um never mind
was that like a private Super Chat I
don't I guess it can't be private
because they Super Chat well he's just
he's like don't they're too long and I
don't like listening to them anyway
London's fine
yeah
okay yeah so anyways
um
Mimi um ain't no way he just said all
that this man took passport Pros to
literal bro leave that marriage and
focus on your ground
numbers Guy what's the church
organization's cut of the money um
seeking God find Jesus he be talking
about Jesus and this this is not Jesus
my friends
Reginald Jackson appreciate your content
looking for a pearl of my own just want
to ask what would happen for modern
women as a whole to self-corrupt
self-correct their destructive Behavior
I feel like women won't correct until
they see consequences and if men and
women keep bailing women out of their
bad decisions then like they're you're
never gonna see and that's why I said 10
10 to 15 you'll see it 10 to 15 years 10
to 15 that's when they're going to start
seeing the consequences of their
behavior yeah okay that's all yeah to go
on that 10 to 15 years is when is when
modern day women are going to see the
consequence of their behaviors they they
don't see it right now yeah no they
don't they don't see it right now which
is why they've got so much
they ain't gonna have that same because
we're starting to see it as a matter of
fact bless it
um there is a video of the YouTube video
as a matter of fact let's see what it's
going to be looking like in the next
maybe 10 to 15
years this is what I'm talking about the
Fallout of feminism lesson let us know
have you are you ready
all right one sec
um because
consequence and accountability is a
thing po
and for me
the modern day woman doesn't she she
lacks it she lacks a concert she lots of
consequences she's actually
accountability but in the next 10 to 15
years we're going to be seeing more of
videos like this
that blessing is going to play right now
yeah there we go oh
I think yeah listen to her
hey tick tock
you know it's crazy because I
um joke a lot about
being single and
you know
I um
I laugh it off
but I'm 46 years old
and while I'm getting ready for surgery
and everything
it dawned on me
hold on
I'm sorry
it dawned on me
that I'm 46 years old
and I don't have a husband to take care
of me
I don't have a husband to
help me
get ready
I'm 46 years old and
I still need my mama
to take care of me post-op
I still need my sister which whether I
had a husband or not they would they
would be there
it sucks
being single and 46
sucks
that's it
but it just sucks
and I'm [ __ ] tired
and I make jokes about
the [ __ ] buffoons that I have been
encountering
in in dating
but in reality this is this is my
reality
this is my reality
this is my reality and this those
stories are the [ __ ] that's available
because all the good men have gotten
married
in their 20s and 30s
because they're good men
I'm not blaming at all on men because
women are [ __ ] [ __ ] they [ __ ]
batshit crazy too so
but I'm this is my reality not anybody
else's
that's all
wow
see
you notice the hoop earrings you know
you know
but but even without the hoop earrings
that
re that realization is coming for so
many women within the next 10 to 15
years
yeah yeah no I that's really sad
um and that's the thing do you think
it's selfish to not get married because
then your family has to take care of you
and then your your family's
responsibility okay so we can talk about
that because he's talking about marriage
right or long term long-term
relationship yeah because
the bottom line is who's gonna look
after you mm-hmm
like he's looking after you like are you
just gonna be single and it's like your
mom and your dad's problem your mom your
dad like maybe if you got children and
they're older than you like that
shouldn't be their job you know their
job but she probably lived a hot girl
summer for what 10 years she said 46.
she's 46 now I was like yeah she looked
good for 40 seconds it's good for 46 but
she probably and that's probably what
the problem is yeah and then she thought
oh my God I look young and I'm gonna let
my hot girl summer yeah like that's 25
years of of [ __ ] yeah literally and
that's the thing that that is what is
coming I wonder if she had next husband
say again I wonder if she had an
ex-husband
I mean look when I see and the thing is
that video
is not in isolation there are so many
videos there's so many videos of women
hitting the wall
right as Kevin Samuel says the may you
rest in power
um and realizing oh my God like what I
was doing
is not working and now I'm single at
this age and it's not working and it's
like that is that like I said with
depression
anger bitterness is coming like what did
they say what did Kevin Samuel say
winter is coming
winter is coming for you ladies okay
it's coming for you but the thing is
because you're so stubborn and because
you don't want to listen and because
everyone's a misogynist and everybody
hates women you are not going to take it
on until the last until the last minute
I'm just a big believer like I feel like
you should always try and a lot of times
like modern women have given up before
they've even tried what do you mean like
they don't listen like they've never
taken a second to listen to what men
want and they'll complain about their
outcomes but you like you didn't even
try
and like that's half of what like men
want to see from women they just want to
see women that like try they're so used
to like not grabbing girls that don't
try at all in the relationship where
they're doing everything women don't
listen Poe you know they listen to their
girlfriends they're in their Echo
Chambers
yeah oh my God he's man of this man of
that yeah yeah girl they oh they
and they'll always sabotage like unless
the guy is an absolute simp they're
gonna sabotage like women's
relationships that they do have when
they are happy unless they're like
they'll only not do it if the guy's an
absolute simp who lets her do whatever
she wants so let's do a let's do a
hypothetical scenarios pill you find a
guy you get married right and
you speak the way you speak within this
space okay right
those those modern day women those
Super Saiyan feminists right they're
gonna try and destroy your relationship
just to make themselves you said need to
be right yeah just to make themselves be
right oh well she couldn't even hold a
relationship down because now they're on
why it's power not in a relationship
what's wrong with her why is she not
married so they're trying to destroy
yourself it's always the personal
attacks but like is what I'm saying true
or is it not true and that's and that's
like that's the that's all you need to
know and you could they could go after
anything yeah everything no I actually I
was thinking I like I feel like I'd
rather date a guy that has no idea like
what my YouTube channel is right it's
like because if they see you in a happy
relationship do you think they're not
going to try and come for that oh no
they will Oh They'll Come for that I
mean I've been in like a public
relationship before and I kind of I've
seen the problems that come with it
Devin it's there's a lot of problems
that come with it addictive and evil man
like I even remember after doing the um
the show that we've done on the possible
Bros right a few weeks ago some of the
comments that I got
from women I'm just like listen if you
because women are like we don't care
about guys going abroad
and on the other hand they're making
whole videos about guys I'm just saying
we should learn from them like that's
what I say like why on Earth if
someone's winning okay like if you see a
a particular demographic winning yeah
winning study them let's yeah let's
let's take notes what recipes you all
know that are making these balls right
yeah exactly but the thing is it's
surprises especially if they're average
looking I'm like but it's the pride of
an eagle Pearl right of the modern day
one the pride and the ego makes them
think that they are the ones that know
everything everyone outside of them
doesn't know ish they don't know [ __ ]
right so it's like what do those
Filipino women know what do those Thai
women something they're the most swiped
real like Asian chicks are the most
swiped right on dating at something no
they don't know nothing because I know
and that's and that is the ego of the
one and that's what they say Pride
becomes pride comes before the fall
that's what's gonna happen to Monday
women
Pride's gonna come before the fall we
got another we got another call yeah we
could do like we can do that one more
yeah like one more we'll do one more
cool thanks listen
who we got
oh we got a lady a girl this never
happens hi
hi sorry
my husband's a big fan that's how I
found your show and I find it very
informative because I've been with my
husband since I was 19. and I'm now 30
and I didn't know anything about modern
dating and it's really opened my eyes
about a lot of people my age or even a
little bit around it
um how her theme
they're treating the dating pool and
it's really eye-opening
do you sense you could tell she's mayor
I could tell she was married when she
opened the calls he's like you feel the
warp coming from though okay like the
happiness like you see that go on what
did you want to say
um so what what made you want to get
married at 19
oh I well
I would say get married at night soon
but um basically married I didn't have
the best uh family life and my dad died
at 18 and I moved out of the house and I
finished high school and then I moved
hundreds of miles away
and I really just wanted to find
somebody who wanted to love me for the
rest of my life and I want to love them
for the rest of their life and that was
the main
goal and then everything through that is
negotiable and working together as long
as we're not
abusing each other in any way and we're
open to improving ourselves
and what do you think of the topic
um The Fallout of feminism 10 to 15
years
where are you at by the way
I don't think Society will end I think
we're always predicting our ends and I
do feel that
When Things become more extreme they end
up plugging themselves off and recenter
kind of like when it gets to elections
it's a race to the edges and then the
race to the middle
um are you familiar with those political
terms no no I'm not I'm not gonna
so when you let's say in the United
States when you're running for a
candidate you race to your political
party Democratic Republican and you're
like completely this and then you're get
to the later stages and then you race to
the middle so you can get some more
votes oh I understand I understand yeah
okay
so when things become extreme eventually
they start recently
so have you
experienced I guess obviously being
married have you seen the experience of
women your age who are not married
um
not really okay
um
um and they who were also married are
they also married no actually no I was
the first one married okay
um but one was a free food and she never
really was ever in a relationship with
people who didn't know that she was that
and she actually recently got married
two years ago
and then I have another friend who
actually has been on a long-term
adventure for structure but um
Adventure what does that mean look
what's a long-term Adventure like she
won
she wanted children and she wanted like
the family and The Purge basis but she
wasn't really seeking
those things out and yeah
but you're like okay
is that your is that your child there
yeah she is she's the one's ready for
bed so she's got the last like 10
minutes before she gets to run around
basically not destroy the house
but be free
where are you at I see what you're
saying with the warmth no that's what
I'm saying like you can like talk you
can tell what someone before I even hear
the kid you could tell when they're like
married and have a family
I'm in Michigan oh okay okay that's what
I've noticed in Michigan people seem to
get married younger and like start
families younger there oh I'm from
California I just moved so my husband
and I after we've been together a while
uh we wanted to be closer to his family
and his father's originally from
Michigan who's gonna retire in a few
years and move back here to his hometown
so we decided to move here and start our
house her family
you know get our house and stuff and
then he's retiring and it's close to a
year or so now and he's gonna be coming
up back here
well thank you for calling in I
appreciate it
yeah thank you guys and have a wonderful
okay bye-bye
you know like a warmth she's got a whole
Christmas house yeah it's like it's like
uh you feel that it's like she's got a
whole it's like just different
one more guy one more yeah okay okay
I'm getting sleepy
I quit coffee today
hi
oh I can't hear you
oh you're muted we can't hear you
um can you hear I can't hear
we can't we we can't hey I think it's I
think it's you because the last the last
guy worked or girl
[Music]
um
is that it is that it done all right
that doesn't work okay well I'm gonna
read the super chats and then we're
gonna close out
um
yeah uh
okay hold on hold on I'm gonna refresh
it okay how's Cheryl says
um
uh oh gosh this is oh I think this is
the one who said she didn't want hers
red okay
um Axel stone is this the feminism after
party perhaps the girl in in the video
is early to the party
um
Justin ginzel uh thank you for the 50
Super Chat I'm thinking yeah we'll do a
little oh wait I'm gonna drop okay I'm
not gonna clap but I wanted to thank you
thank you for all your work Pearl we
need more people like you who aren't
afraid to pursue truth out here
um okay that's it is that it yeah that's
it all right so that has been the the
gray area up you know this is the first
time we've done like a live yeah like a
live calling show yeah cooling show
um do you guys like this format if you
do let us know in the comments yeah let
us know
um if you prefer this format or the
format we've got like 500 people like
saying some stuff but yeah Pearl thank
you
um
you know I'm just going to say I've been
here from the beginning you've been here
from the beginning I've been there from
the beginning before they all saw it I'm
sorry before they saw it okay so when
people ask who the hell Sarah Garvey and
I've been here from the beginning bro
like third episode from third episode
yeah that was a great episode too so get
to know but if you want to say anything
before we close out let them know
um not really guys like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel uh
listen go and subscribe to my channel
okay yeah go subscribe his link is in
the description my link is in the
description I need to get to 100K by
next year it's it is it is stupid he's
not at 100K it's ridiculous ridiculous I
go viral every week every week every
week I'm going viral big up Sarah Garvey
like bring up big up myself I'm going
viral every week on like and then like
and people aren't subscribing so
subscribe subscribe
go on pal you can close out okay guys
um a couple announcements before we end
the show subscribe to both our Clips
channels subscribe to Pearl behind the
scenes um I want to get monetized on
there but I'll do like streams I'll play
guitar sometimes yeah I just do random
stuff you want to see like what I do in
my day-to-day life go subscribe to that
um also like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel
um subscribe to wife school too uh we
want to get to 10K on that we have our
first up